i'm ethan i'm elizabeth and we are from
cheap old houses on hgtv and discovery
plus
and if we could do one thing it would be
to buy secondhand reuse things look at
thrift stores look at vintage shops that
stuff not only is good for the
environment but adds so much character
to your house why are cheaper houses
environmentally friendly
you reusing a house you're recycling a
house you're not starting from scratch
you're walking into a house and you're
saying what's here that's already good
that i don't need to change out nothing
is more environmentally friendly than
keeping what's already there
you don't have to bring in new building
supplies you don't have to demolish
things you don't have to have new
construction costs
walk into a kitchen and say
i don't love these cabinets but how can
i use the existing materials what can i
repaint what can i change around a
little bit but i don't have to throw
everything out
it's getting out of the mindset of new
new new and thinking about saving and
keeping and preserving history that's
good for the house that's good for your
wallet and that's really good for the
environment i think a ton of people
think about old houses as like drafty
old houses but think about building
costs and think about building materials
talk about the embodied energy in that
building you are saving a ton of the
environment by just buying a cheap old
house
i'm so glad we don't have to buy plywood
like everyone else right now because we
already have it in the house literally
like lumber is super expensive i think
buying secondhand is so important this
stuff is already created and there's so
much good stuff out there you don't need
something that's brand new off the shelf
collect buy vintage you know walk into
thrift stores there's so much that can
add so much more personality to your
house than anything new on the shelf
that stuff not only is good for the
environment but adds so much character
to your house for more tips head to the
drew barrymore show at thedrewberrymore
show.com
[Music]
you